the Joe Rogan experience I flash this up
you didn't this was a take it in
Northridge a week ago
what is that mountain line on someone's
road [ __ ] hell like there's two of
them
why Northridge two on the roof at the
same time oh my god it's so hide your
kids hide your wife yeah well they're
looking for dogs and cats one of the
things they found out when they killed
them in San Francisco and the Bay Area
they have they have real problems up
there sometimes especially some of those
homes that like like sort of like like
we have Malibu with the mountain lions
live real yeah close proximity with the
people so they do these stomach
examinations they find it's like half
dogs and cats well the cat that I said
that could open doors and [ __ ] he wanted
nothing more to than to kill mon amour
my other cats he was a Russian blue had
three legs and he was really really
smart we adopted him and um we tried for
like six months to make it work we tried
everything everything you could think of
to make brought a criminal into your
home exactly and I didn't know and we
had to we rehomed him with my
brother-in-law and his wife and he like
got along with the dog and was having
the best time and show me he thought he
[ __ ] ran [ __ ] he thought he owned to
the neighborhood and he ended up getting
eaten by a mountain lion yeah yeah three
legs versus a mountain lion Morgan
smartest fastest three legged animal
you've ever seen but [ __ ] yeah and
mountain lion one maybe he's a little
cocky for his own good a thousand
percent
he thought he ran [ __ ] that's hilarious
imagine the moment when you realize that
that's a giant you [ __ ] you jack most
animals and then you realize oh my god
this is a hundred and forty on me yeah
[ __ ] hey it was never seen again bro
we're so weird that we let those things
just wander around us we're so weird
I always think it's really strange that
I live with another species in my house
I think about that very often
I mean mountain lion oh yeah it's
supposed to watch like it's some
Holocaust and killing them all genocide
I don't I don't think they don't get me
wrong I don't think we should kill them
all I'm saying is it's really
interesting that we have this thing that
we sort of agree rarely rarely kills
people but it does sometimes and we want
to keep it around
sounds an awful lot like the sharks bro
and
that they're running out of [ __ ] to eat
you know we're gonna have a yeah thing
listen well the last time you saw a deer
I mean fairly recently but but but not
often it's here it's pretty rare even if
you live where deer are like I used to
growing up in the suburbs of New York I
used to see deer like daily do you think
deer on the pill no thanks going I've
lived in a city and I haven't paid
attention to the deer in the suburb let
me tell you what's what's happened man
cats oh they've moved in and start
jacking deer and coyotes what didn't
start jacking deer and the hats are
[ __ ] up deer big cats Bobcats are
[ __ ] up deer oh everybody's [ __ ]
up the fawns everybody's [ __ ] right
babies yeah yeah so when the babies are
born they have zero chance these big
[ __ ] sons big wild dogs
the Coyotes everywhere just California a
side of LA mostly around us if you go to
like Iowa they they have too many deer
like you'll be driving why water hunting
deer not mountain lion
well you can't hunt mountain lion in
California they don't have is there a
pretty predatory cat that you can't bet
you should hunt I mean I don't know you
can give that well see the thing is like
the the people think that you need to
control their populations where the
argument is it gets real interesting
because it branches off between people
that are very much animal advocates
animal rights first they want animals to
rule and to be able to have their own
freedom on their land
yeah and just whatever happens happens
like mountain lions killing deer and all
that kind of stuff and let it all take
place and we shouldn't interfere with
that and we shouldn't hunt there's
people that really think like that and
you know they have their arguments and
they have their the reasons but the
reality of animals is if you have large
predators and the large predators runs
out of things to eat it's either going
to go further and enter into new areas
looking for food and it might get hit by
cars or it's gonna branch out already
expand its going to expand its range and
in expanding its range it's gonna find a
farm or it's gonna find a dog in the
backyard it's gonna find something
because it's just trying to get food and
like how many of those we will
to have around us yeah like I'm not
saying that we should kill mountain
lions I think it's wonderful endangered
now not really so why can't we kill me
okay well California doesn't it yeah
well count the only time California
kills them really is when they get
what's called a depredation order like
um if someone has something happened
like if you run a farm in a mountain
lion starts killing your livestock which
does happen yeah a lady in Malibu a few
years back had a I think it was an
alpaca farm huh and this [ __ ]
mountain lion killed like a ton of them
it was just killing them they seemed
easy to kill though I think it killed a
goat too I think it was just getting a
kick out of killing things you know it
was just fun and but they said it wasn't
even eating him which is really nuts
that's strange I think he couldn't get
it out you know it's probably a really
big animal and he couldn't get it out he
probably didn't feel comfortable enough
to eat it while he's in there so he's
probably really healed them all at once
oh well I think it was over a couple of
days but it was kind of a killing spree
see if it man it's like we just killed
for fun first of all when you think
about mal but do you really think about
an alpaca farm no well no I think of
that in Topanga
[Laughter]
[Applause]